we do join you tonight during a truly
historic moment in Israel's history one
that is cause for great celebration this
week not only has President Donald Trump
chosen to withdraw from the disastrous
Obama Iran nuclear deal but we are here
on the eve of the momentous opening of
the American Embassy in Jerusalem a move
that recognizes Jerusalem as the capital
of Israel a move greatly appreciated by
the people of Israel as evidenced on
street corners everywhere we went
president Trump's pullout from the Iran
deal
although suspected became a virtual
certainty when Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu proved through Israel's
intelligence agency Mossad that Iran had
been lying to the world when it was
continuing uranium enrichment and
nuclear development Iranian documents
uncovered by that same Intel agency are
proof positive that Iran lied
gee what a shock on the day of the
withdrawal from the Iran deal bomb
shelters opened up in the Golan Heights
and the Israeli army was on high alert
as Israel brace for imminent attack as
we proceeded from Haifa to the Golan
Heights there were no sirens school
buses and taxis continued to run but
that night in Tiberias we heard the
unequivocal sound of rockets and a
breakfast we found out that indeed there
was an Iranian rocket offensive toward
Israel from inside Syria Israel
responded with strategic precision
targeting munitions storage warehouses
logistics headquarters and Intel systems
of Iran within its proxy Syria Israel
does what Israel needs to do and today
Iranians are actually marching against
the United States
protesting president Trump's decision to
withdraw from their nuclear deal maybe
they ought to consider protesting that
the hundred and fifty billion dollars
Obama gave them
- wasn't used to benefit them that
instead it was used to support both its
nuclear development as well as its
military budget which has grown by
almost 40% now Obama's Iran deal make no
mistake
destroyed 70 years of bipartisan US
foreign policy in the Middle East his
delusional deal abandoned Israel and
Egypt largest Arab country and alienated
the Sunni Muslims the moderate Arab
states guaranteeing that they would face
a nuclear Iran Iran of course a leading
state sponsor of terror exports
dangerous missiles and supports
terrorist proxies and militias like
Hezbollah Hamas and the Taliban the idea
that it seeks a successful nuclear
energy program is absurd to even anyone
with half a brain and as Obama turned
his back on the slaughter of Christians
and ignored his own red line in the
serious sand he allowed Russia through
this vacuum to become a dominant
regional player in the Middle East
Donald Trump's withdrawal from that deal
was the United States standing shoulder
to shoulder with our ally Israel against
the rest of the world it sent a huge
signal to Iran and Shia Muslims that we
stood with the more moderate Sunnis and
although Great Britain and France had
joined the United States earlier and
taking out Syrian rep a weapons facility
they chose to stand with Iran against
Israel and the United States but Trump
has reassured the world that his word is
worth more than any former US presidents
like Bill Clinton George Bush and Barack
Obama who all promised to move the
embassy to Jerusalem but didn't deliver
his word is worth more than any treaty
and stronger than any UN resolution he
promised and he delivered Trump not only
sends a message to Iran but to Russia as
well that the u.s. is back
as a dominant regional player after the
Obama years he recognizes a reality that
everyone else in the West willingly wins
themselves to and that is that Jerusalem
is the one and only capital of Israel by
Trump pudding is infra mater on what has
been history for the last three thousand
years and that is that Jerusalem has
been the capital of one people's country
or one kingdom that people is the Jews
and that country is and was Israel the
empires that tried to destroy Israel and
its capital Jerusalem are long gone yet
the Jews still speak the same language
and practice the same religion which is
the foundation of our judeo-christian
nation Donald Trump's and Iranian who
are the descendants of Persia a message
to reflect on their own history and that
it was the king of Persia who a thousand
years before Mohammed was even born
that said Jerusalem was the capital of
the Jewish people's country there will
be no Ottoman empires or chien nations
that will destroy Jerusalem any longer
Donald Trump recognized history he like
King Cyrus before him fulfilled the
biblical prophecy of the gods worshipped
by Jews Christians and yes Muslims that
Jerusalem is the eternal capital of the
Jewish state and that the Jewish people
finally deserve a righteous free and
sovereign Israel